moi je m'appelle bastien et la mairesse
et sophie ma mère a eu trois maris mon
père c'est philippe le beau gosse
populaire après elle a épousé claude ils
ont eu ma soeur clarac et puis alors en
contre hugo tu as et les bim montus
frères l'hiver avant moi finit pas eu
l'oscar mclaglen larouche léopoldine
juliette c'est ma cousine défi d'agnès
agnès c'est la petite soeur de maman
elle a eu léopoldine ipod et juliette
elle a perdu son père un vieil qui
paraît que c'est ma grand mère l'avocat
kantien quoi boire et sinon il a déjà un
premier fils de babel elliott la famille
nombreuse qui par excès réac mais la
famille nombreuse recomposée ça c'est
nouveau et décontractée